So I want to tell you about pustules purism, which is a Ferrum,
which blew the minds of 19th century mathematicians. Um,
it was a really exciting moment.
A lot of people tried to come up with their own proofs.
I'm not going to explain the proof.
I just want to tell you what it's about and maybe a little bit about why it's so
cool and surprising. And I have to admit, I don't know what a poor ism is.
Some people call it pustules closure theorem, but purism is so cool.
But that's what we're going to use today.
You didn't know what a poorer is and don't know what a poor person is.
Well, Google that, but it means like a theorem or probably.
I, I don't even want to venture a guess. It could, it could mean anything.
So you start with two conics, but like two ellipses,
let's say one is inside the other. And what do you do?
You start with a point on one and you draw the tangent line to the other one
through that point, one of the tangent lines, and it intersects the other conic.
At some point,
now you can take this point and draw while we already have one tangent line
through this point and the second conic, but you draw the other one,
how you get a third point and you keep going and you draw out the tangent line
and you keep bouncing around.
Eventually, maybe you close up.
So you might get back to where you started. So you might yeah.
Get back to where you started.
After some number of times bouncing around this picture. You might not
here's the theorem. So suppose you eventually get back to where you started.
So you started at this point,
you bounced around a lot and eventually you come back.
Then the same thing happens if you start at any point.
So all you have to know is that if you start here,
you bounce around you come back. Well, what happens if you started here?
The same thing would be true.
You'd bounced around a bunch of times and eventually you'd come back to where
you started. So that's [inaudible]
and.
By extension, if you don't come back to where you started,
that's also true for any point. Yes.
Right? Because if it was true for some other point,
then while you would know, there's some point where you start in,
bounced around. So for your original point,
you'd also by the same theorem have to bounce around.
You can come back to where you started. That's the result. So,
okay. So why was this so exciting? I'm not going to say much about the proof,
but the reason why is that the proof used some objects, huddle, elliptic curves,
or elliptic functions, which were really exciting at the time.
And everyone had to come up with their own proof of this using elliptic
functions or elliptic curves.
And people were still doing that as late as like the 1960s or 1970s,
including some of the giants of algebraic geometry.
So that was the shiny new toy of mathematics at the time.
And I think it was just really exciting.
There's some, you know, fairly elementary statement you could make,
that you could apply is really fancy. New tools is really exciting and,
you know, beautiful objects to study and improve. What's the first using.
That or was it already proven? And then people came along and said,
I bet we could do that with elliptic.
What happened was peninsula is proof didn't, uh,
didn't intrinsically use these ideas or didn't,
he didn't know maybe he was using these ideas. And then a little bit later,
Jacoby came along and he was like, Oh,
I know how to prove this using elliptic integrals.
But this was right at the beginning of the time,
people were starting to understand elliptic curves,
which actually came from some interest in calculus problems or elliptic
integrals. And so, uh, I think the excitement came from, you know,
people looking at Palm solos proof and realizing, Oh,
there's something really beautiful happening here.
What properties of the ellipses make a joining star?
And what ones make them not join? Or is it just a random thing.
That there's, there's some, uh,
some really beautiful geometry hidden here associated to these two contacts.
There's a sort of diagram like this. So it's a,
some kind of parallelogram or you think of these sides as the same.
And these sides is the same.
So actually this is one way of thinking about what the curve is,
a picture like this, and also is associated to it a little arrow. So a vector.
And here's another thing you can do just like this and other kind of operation.
You can perform on a picture like this. You can add the vector to itself,
so you can do this and then do this. And well, maybe you get here,
but that's the same as this point.
Cause we said that these two sites were the same, but do this, do this.
And that's the same as this point. Just the same as this point.
And the way we can tell if you wrap around and get to where you get is exactly
this. If the same thing is true on this picture, if,
once you add the specter to itself, enough times,
you get back to where you started.
So this is the associated elliptic curve.
I don't see the link between the parallelogram and the yeah. It's I,
I haven't told it to. Yeah. So in fact, I can say a little bit about it.
So what you do is you identify this with, let me give the conics names.
So this inner one is C and this one is D so you identify this with the set of
points, C and D,
where C is a point of C and D is a point of D and the
line through C and D is tangent to C
to point C.
And it turns out there's a natural way to go from the set to this parallelogram
in particular, it has this kind of additional law on it.
So if I said to you, Daniel,
I want you to draw two ellipses that will work,
that will create this cool property.
You would use that to try to reverse engineer.
Okay, cool. Yeah.
It's funny. When you started talking about elliptic curves,
you didn't draw a single curve line.
Right? Yeah. So, so a, an elliptic curve, people often draws looking at like,
something like this.
So that's the real solutions to an equation that looks like
this. But, uh, if you, instead, you look at the complex solutions,
you've got a picture like this. So, and so in fact, this is,
if you think about gluing this side to this side and this side to this side.
You've got.
A donut and what's this picture as well.
This loop goes over here and this one is kind of something shadow of a loop over
here. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Our thanks to brilliant for supporting today's episode,
brilliant is an amazing collection of quizzes and courses and daily
challenges, all sorts of things you can do to really sharpen your brain.
It's great for just some fun passing the time or really going deep into subjects
that maybe you feel like you're not across like number theory or calculus or
probability.
I've been lucky enough to meet some of the people at brilliant I've even been to
their offices.
They're so passionate about making people smarter about educating the world.
They hope you not only go and use brilliant,
but they're also supporting all sorts of science and mathematics outreach.
Like number five, if you want to go check out what they're doing,
go to brilliant.org/number file. The slash number file,
lets them know you came from here,
but also gets you 20% of their premium subscription.
If you decide to sign up for that and the premium subscription gets you all the
good stuff, brilliant.org/number four,
our thanks to them as always for supporting our videos.